eric lauer is a guy that
has been waiting for this moment he's
been down there with the alternate
training site he gets his chance against
the reigning world champs here tonight
yeah first start of the 2021 season last
year in a short year first impression
with the brewers not so good with the
dra over 13 didn't get a win
on about face good start for eric lauer
a backwards k to start his night
but a great dodger debut for trevor
bauer he's fourth in the league in
strikeouts he's second in the league and
opponents average the league hitting 135
against him
seven pitched along
he
[Applause]
with just enough room
long puts a scare into bauer in the
dodgers first batter of the game but
taylor's there one away
here is omar narbaez
now 102
goes back to it and gets squeezed did
not get the call that was a great
curveball when you're looking at it
especially from the left side doesn't it
look like it's in the zone for a moment
that time it was he went a little higher
with a curveball and struck him out
swinging so bauer gets him in order in
the bottom of the first inning
power two garcia with an o2
got him with a high fast ball four up
and four down for trevor bauer
one man out travis shaw the batter
100 against the curve shaw bangs this
one in the air deep to right bets to the
track just enough
[Applause]
that is a couple of warning track
fly-outs over the first two innings
mookie betts
comes to the plane struck out looking
his first time up 3-2 the count and a
call strike three lauer
gets him again mookie bet strikes out
looking for the second consecutive
at-bat bradley the long-time boston red
sox in his first season with the
milwaukee brewers
jackie bradley jr right field mookie
betts looks up it's off the base of the
wall jbj on his way to second base
it's a double to start the third inning
for jackie bradley jr the brewers have
their first hit of the game
here's colton juan two outs and a runner
at second base
power to wong one one
breaking ball pulled to second and
sheldon noisy will end the ending
what a way for max muncie
it's happening sharply oh what a play
rhys
and a low throw this one is dug out by
vogelback
has made some outstanding plays with the
glove he's still having some trouble
throwing the baseball but this time his
big first baseman picks him up he's
making first baseman and particularly
daniel vogelbach work
two-hour walk this time around with
travis shaw coming up
shaw in the air right field it is
hooking it is going to stay fair
goodbye
two-run shot for travis shaw
the brewers take the lead as shaw pops
number four
and now 19 rbis on the year to lead the
club
there's that 12-6 breaking ball weighted
on it perfectly
and allow the bat to stay through the
zone so that it doesn't hulk bow very
true straight away
and a huge two-nothing lead for the
brewers
dodgers hoping for a similar outcome to
a two-out walk that the brewers got in
the bottom of the fourth
yanks it down online based it up the
middle
lucky bets with a two out single third
first and second with two guard so quick
visit for lauer
season debut no runs over four and two
thirds but the dodgers with multiple
base runners here and cory seiber coming
up
first time a runner in scoring position
all night for the dodgers 2-2 and in the
air left field playable for taylor and
lauer is going to get through it
a bit self-inflicted walking the pitcher
but he has delivered five shutout
innings
and eric lauer for whatever reason is cy
young against the dodger and not against
everybody else
tyrone taylor and jackie bradley jr will
face trevor bauer in the bottom of the
seventh inning
two two
two out got a chase on a slider for his
fifth
99 pitch tonight is another one two and
it's a back door breaker to sit him down
back to back kaze to finish off this
seventh
and here he is devin williams the man
who's got the eight
and he'll make his tenth appearance
chris and he'll have the top of the
order coming up
seeger a shot on a hop
maria is to won't look at this play
throw first yes oh my goodness what a
double play
oh
man
as good as it gets
i mean you're thinking get one and be
happy
colton wong says i got two gold gloves
for a reason two on two outs max muncie
dangerous hitter in a spot like this
muncie on the ground the shift is on
shaw's got it winds it up the throw is
in time
he's out he's out they won't challenge
it over howard digging deep here at 111
pitches
one out away from completing eight
innings and then just begging for some
semblance of offense because we're
talking about the bullpen game
needed to go deep in the game giving
them a chance to come back here's his
1-0 pitch
into the ground backhand turner and
trevor bauer goes eight innings tonight
in milwaukee
dodgers will try to do it against josh
hayder
to give bauer the outcome he deserves
with that effort
runaway
sheldon noisy is the batter
full
count down he goes
hater with a strikeout
doubled him up with that slider
and back-to-back case for josh hader
and so barnes who's reached in six of
his last 11 played appearances
hands in
[Applause]
doubles up again
they're still alive it's 2-1 as taylor
scores austin barnes with a pin shake
single
time run aboard
go ahead run at the plate in the form of
mookie betts
coming down to the finish line here
tonight in the night hater deals swing
and a drive that is into right field
playable for garcia and the ball game is
over
and the brewers win this one two to one